and then you go to Dany she feels empty
it wasn't what she thought it was it's
not enough every single thing it's
letter to this point and there she is
alone we've all got this part of us it's
that part that goes I'm going to put that
chocolate cake down and I'm going to walk
away we come up against those moral
conundrums all the time not saying
chuckling he's a moral conundrum eat as
much cake as you want but those things
that you wrestle with in yourself she
knows she has won this war it's in that
moment when she makes the decision to
make this personal it's one of my
favorite Amelia performance moments
because it took place on the back of
like a giant green dragon buck without a
real thing anywhere in sight I mean is
really nice and she cares she's a whole
bunch of things that done isn't so
reaching this part of Danny is it it was
a tough call for ultimately she is who
she is and that's a Targaryen and you
know she has said repeatedly throughout
the show I will take what is mine with
fire and blood and in this episode she
does it
for the audience only want it about well
here you go hi everyone it's Charlie
this is going to be my Game of Thrones
season eight episode 6 finale trailer
video obviously there's so much to talk
about we have to talk about the footage
what's actually happening or reaction to
all this and then all the things in the
background that the show is paying off
or in the books and what George RR Martin's
supposed book ending is going to be
and whether or not that's going to be
different from the show's ending I've
seen a lot of questions about that
recently like if the show is doing this
ending does that mean that George RR
Martin is going to change his book ending
so I will add some clips from that
George RR Martin himself has said a lot
about that in the last couple of months
and Season eight is premiered so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Game of Thrones
videos I will be talking about the game
of Thrones prequel TV shows in the next
week because that'll be the next big
thing that we'll move on to this summer
after they start shooting it after the
game of Thrones finale so obviously the
next couple of weeks will be us talking
about the finale and the series as a
whole trying to put everything into
context but there is a bonus episode
that they're going to air sort of like an
episode 7 the week after the finale airs
so two more weeks technically a game of
Thrones you should be able to watch that
episode the same way you watch all the
other Game of Thrones episodes so no
worries and there is a new round of that
HBO now giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so starting with
the footage we have Jon Snow and Davos
walking through the wreckage of the city
trying to take it all in
Tyrion doing the same thing in a
separate part of the city with the same
look of shock and horror on his face
that he had after season 7 episode 4
when Daenerys attacked the Lannister
troops there's a shot of Arya walking
around the unsullied troops looking up
at Daenerys as she walks out of the red
keep to address everyone a wide shot of
the unsullied in formation and all the
Dothraki cheering in victory with our
rocks held high big surprise if you
thought that all the Dothraki were
during the long night episode
there was so much confusion after
episode 3 that they had to come out and
say no they lost half of their forces
because the way they filmed it made it
seem like that went out away differently
then you get that final shot Daenerys
slowly walking out from behind to make
the post war victory speech in
proclamation about her New World Order
so to speak this is how everything is
going to be in my new Kingdom but the
thing is is the music through this whole
trailer is very ominous and you look at
all the Dothraki formations marching
around in synchronicity in all this
the tree seems very sinister within that
context you can make as many allusions
or comparisons to real-world tyrants but
obviously I think this is just the
beginning of what could potentially
being a run at a Mad Queen so even
though she kind of turned during the
episode and Emilia Clarke tries to
explain that how Daenerys sort of
succumbed to the worst things within her
how we all fight that moral conundrum in
the way she sort of talks about it
Daenerys spiraled out of control so this
is just the beginning of that descent
and you have all these other characters
the main characters trying to figure out
what they're going to do about it next a
lot of them look really confused except
for Arya Stark so you have a situation
where Daenerys is basking in the ashes
of her victory I don't want to be the
queen of ashes but yet look at all these
ashes falling around her and I think
they're trying to mislead you a little
bit into thinking that Arya is going to be
the person to end the threat of Daenerys
like she's clearly got that look on her
face like she's developing a plan so we
definitely think she wants to try and
deal with Daenerys but think about it
this way there's still a chance that the
show could pay off a couple really big
George RR Martin prophecies from the
books of A Song of Ice and Fire the
prophecy of azor Ahai the prince who was
promised in a couple of Daenerys his
biggest visions from the house of the
undying that we're just now seeing
unfold on screen particularly the one of
her in the iron throne room but also a
cup of the other ones in there too
because you re-examine those visions in
the context of what's happened the last
couple of episodes and they mean very
different things and like you talk about
foreshadowing the official poster is
dragons eyes transposed with the Iron
Throne I think that Daenerys is going to
wind up destroying the Iron Throne
literally with drogon because Aegon the
conquerer when he was making the Iron
Throne had to use blaring the black
dread to melt all the swords down there
been a lot of book readers ever since
Dance with Dragons was published that
have wondered if Daenerys is going to be
Jon Snow's Nissa Nissa within the Azor Ahai prophecy there's just one of
George RR Martin's biggest prophecies that
seemingly foreshadows the end we've just
all been thinking about it in the wrong
context that it was all about the night
king when really it seems like it's more
about this endgame with Jon Snow and
Daenerys so if you're not familiar with
the full text of the story of azor Ahai
it reads like this darkness lay over the
world in a hero Azor Ahai was chosen to
fight against it to fight the darkness
azor Ahai needed to forge a hero's sword
he labored for 30 days and 30 nights
until it was done however when he went
to temper
in water the sword broke he was not one
to give up easily so he started over the
second time he took fifty days and fifty
nights to make the sword even better
than the first to temper at this time he
captured a lion and drove the sword into
its heart but once more the steel
shattered the third time with a heavy
heart for he knew beforehand what he
must do to finish the blade he worked
for a hundred days in a hundred nights
until it was finished this time he
called for his wife Nissa Nissa and
asked her to bear her breasts he drove
the sword into her living heart her soul
combining with the steel of the sword
creating Lightbringer the red sword of
Heroes then the story goes on to say
that azor Ahai didn't fight alone he had
people helping him he thrust his blade
through a monster in the monster burst
into flames so for the past six seven
eight years maybe even longer than that
for some people have wondered if
Daenerys will be Jon Snow's Nissa Nissa
he'll her to prevent her from
becoming full Mad Queen and
quote-unquote Forge Lightbringer by
thrusting long cloth through her heart
that would also fulfill Denise's
prophecy in the House the undying the
three has the dragon three treasons you
will know once for blood once for gold
and once for love because Jon Snow loves
Daenerys too much to see her turn into
the Mad Queen the Easter eggs that
they're paying off from Daenerys visions
in the house the entire probably
recognized a couple them too
particularly the destroyed iron throne
room because Daenerys was literally
destroying the red keep during last
night's episode the three heads of the
Dragon prophecy goes like this three
fires you must light one for life one
for death and one for love three mounts
you must ride one to bed wanted red and
one to love three treasons you will know
once for blood once for gold in once for
love so remember this is a book prophecy
they didn't do it on the TV show because
some of the characters that fulfill this
prophecy are characters that the TV show
did not wind up doing of the three fires
you must light one for life was Khal
Drogo's funeral pyre that allowed her
three dragons to hatch one for death was
the burning of the Dothraki Khals during
season 6 on the show one to love was
the metaphorical fire that she lit in
her heart for Jon Snow loving someone
again after Khal Drogo like she told
Sansa earlier this season the last man
that I loved was taller so that means
she never truly loved Daario naharis so
sick burn on Daario but like in last
night's episode they're standing in
front of that fire while she's
confessing her love for Jon Snow and he
rejects her so you could also interpret
it that way two of the three mounts you
must ride the one to bed was either a
Khal Drogo or you could look at it as
the white horse the Khal Drogo gave her
on their wedding night it's name was
silver one to dread was drogon they
called balerion the black dread you
dread dragons and the one to love is
obviously Jon Snow she mounted Jon Snow
of the three treasons you will know once
for blood once for gold once for love
the one for blood was Illyrio probably
because in the books we find out that
book Aegon was really his son and he's a
Targaryen bastard not a true Targaryen
like they're telling him he is there's a
whole of the story line that the show
has cut out with the golden company in a
whole other version of Aegon that might
wind up being Illyrio's illegitimate son
the one for gold was brown been plumb in
the books he's one of the second sons
who betrays Daenerys to join the
opposing young Chi Army when she was
still fighting them then obviously the
betrayal for love is probably Jon Snow
when he like I said because he
loves her too much to allow her to turn
into full Mad Queen like the Mad King
her father that would be the bittersweet
tragic ending that George RR Martin has
been warning us about this whole time
and when you think about Daenerys
visions in the house of the undying on
the TV show in that bittersweet context
the scene in the throne room makes a lot
more sense now she's victorious she's
won the Iron Throne she's taking King's
Landing but the castle is in ruins only
because she's destroyed it herself
instead of snow falling around them
because it's still winter it's the ashes
of everything that she's just burned so
she's in the throne room she's the queen
of ashes and she doesn't actually get to
touch the iron throw she comes within
hands reach of it that has to turn away
to walk through the door which in
earlier context before we got in these
final episodes most of us thought was
just her getting a vision of the coming
of the night King like she would go
beyond the wall she would lose Viserion
but now when you think about the
potential ending of the show
Daenerys dying at Jon Snow's hands this
vision of her walking through the door
might be her leaving the world of the
living a vision of her like she's
passing into the afterlife it makes a
lot more sense then that she sees Khal
Drogo in her baby Rago because there in
the afterlife
so if she were to die then she would
join them in and get to see them
again depending on what you actually
think happens after within the
world of A Song of Ice and Fire
Jon Snow claims that he saw nothing he
claims it was all just blackness so I
think a lot of that is open to
interpretation so it seems like George
RR Martin has always been foreshadowing
that Daenerys would be the final threat
of A Song of Ice and Fire based on a lot
of the internal monologue she gets
during her POV chapters and what her
fate would be at the hands of Jon Snow
based on a lot of the clues that he lays
in all these prophecies and
foreshadowing I think the biggest
criticism of the show is that the show
is just done a very poor job at adapting
that narrative and pacing it out so that
all the character turns and
foreshadowing makes sense by the end
there's probably the biggest comment
that I've seen about this last season is
way to rush we really needed a couple
more seasons to do this story justice so
then you asked how different is the TV
show ending going to be from George RR
Martin's book ending and Song of Ice and
Fire
so here's a clip of what George RR Martin
had to say about that
I don't think Dan and Dave's ending is
going to be that different from my ending
because of the conversations we we did
have but they may be on certain
secondary characters that may be the big
differences he's trying to say that the
ending won't be exactly the same
there'll be a lot of secondary
characters and lesser stuff that's a
little bit different some of the players
will be a little bit different but the
biggest characters like Jon Snow
Daenerys Arya Stark Tyrion all the
things that happened to them will be
pretty much the same thing that happens
to them at the end of the book story the
follow-up question that I know a lot of
you have though is that now that
everyone's going to know the ending of
the story will Martin go back in and
change a bunch of things because it's
going to take him years and years to finish
dream of spring we don't even have winds
of winter yet this is another clip of
him talking about whether or not he
would change his story just because
people start to figure out what the
ending might be but what do you do then
do you change it and come up with
something goofy and outlandish that you
haven't led thee you haven't done the
foreshadowing for that you haven't laid
the foundation for just in order to
surprise people I mean sure I could have
like aliens come down and that would
certainly surprised the hell out of
everybody no one is predicting that but
it would ruin the series he's given that
interview a couple different times and
he always says pretty much the same
thing so even though a lot of side plots
might change a little bit the really big
arcs and the really big beats for the
huge characters won't change that much
so obviously it's going to probably be like
10 or 12 years before we actually find
out what the real bookending is for
dream of spring so we'll check back in
ten twelve years later to see how
different the TV show ending was but
like I said what's going to happen is is
the Game of Thrones prequel will start
filming this summer there's actually
three in development but only one of
them is shooting right now that's going to
premiere next year and George RR Martin
is working with other people not Dan and
Dave dan and Dave are not involved with
the Game of Thrones prequel TV series at
all they're going to go off and do their
own thing so they won't be involved with
the Game of Thrones franchise anymore
after this I'll talk a little bit about
what's going on with those prequel TV
shows in the next couple of weeks but
leave all your requests in the comments
below obviously I'll be doing a Q&A
video so leave all your questions in the
comments for that too congratulations to
the giveaway winner from my last big
video machete oh please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here for my
Game of Thrones season 8 episode 5 video from
last night and click here for my episode 4
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!